Take a look at the main page of the alphabet. Notice A, B, C, D, E, F all end in alpha. G, H, I,
J, K, L all end in beta and M through V all end in gamma. If you see a motion combination that
ends in alpha you can already narrow it down to just the first six letters A, B, C, D, E, or
F. If you see one that ends in beta you know it's G, H, I, J, K, or L and if you see one
ending in gamma you know it's one of the letters M through V. We've already talked about
A, B, and C which are the three letters that go from alpha to alpha. D, E, and F start in beta
and end in alpha. In the kinetic alphabet motion combinations are categorized by the end position
and the path it took to get there. The group A, B, and C is going to work differently than the
group D, E, and F. To review if we do an A and then we follow through with the exact same hand
path we'll do another A and then if we follow through it'll be another A another A. D, E, and
F don't work like that because they follow an opposite hand path. The letters D, E, and F start
in beta and end in alpha. The letters J, K, and L start in alpha and end in beta. With this
understanding we can create three combinations of these compound letters D, J, E, K, and F,
L. In this video we're going to explore D, J, and several ways to accomplish it. We're
going to start thumbs in but it would be equally valid to start any sequence thumbs out
or one thumb in one thumb out. So we'll start at this low beta position and we're going to
isolate both of them up and end in alpha and that was D. If we follow through with that
motion and go from alpha to beta it's J. Now let's reverse that we open back up D and we close
J. One more time open D close to J open D close J. We can also follow through with the
hand path and cross our hands. Let's do it again we open to D close J. Now we're going to have to
pick one hand to go in front of the other so let's pick the right hand just to have something
consistent. The right hand is going to travel in front the left hand is going to stay closer
to my body and I'm going to cross my hands and do D again and then I follow through with
that we'll be in beta. Let's do exactly that the same way again D J now pass the right in
front D J. One more time D J D J. You'll notice there's a natural way that I turn my body whenever
I pass my right in front and that would be leaning back to my right like so. Now let's
pass the left in front D J now I'll take my left bring it further from me on my right
closer to me D J and you'll notice I naturally will move to my back left while accomplishing
that D J D J. Now that we've done it both ways let's alternate sides first we'll have the right
pass in front then we'll have the left pass in front. Starting this low beta D J pass the right
in front D J once again D J pass the left in front D J. A couple more times D J pass the
right in front D J D J pass the left in front D J. One more time D J right in front D J D J left
in front D J. So that's D J facing the audience and crossing arms just like we did with A B and
C we can also do body turns. So if I start in this low beta here I'm going to aim to turn
my body to the right. It's going to start the exact same way D J but by J now I've already turned
and I'm facing the right. Now my right hand is going to pass behind me closest to the curtain
and my left hand is going to come in front of me as they do their isolations D J and then
I'm back home. Let's do that a couple more times D J is the same except now I'm turned
now my right comes down left comes down D J once again D J D J D J D J. We can also do it on the
other side start the same way D and now I'm going to turn to my left as I do J now my left is
going to come down behind me with an isolation and my right is going to come in front of me
D and now my left keeps going down my right keeps going down J. Let's do that a couple
times D J left comes down behind me D J D J D J D J D J D J and then I'm home.
And just like we did before let's do it on both sides alternating we'll go to the right
and then to the left and we're going to do that four times start in this low beta here
D J turn to the right right hand comes down behind you D J and we're home do it on the
other side D J turn to the left left comes down behind you D J and we're home D J turn to the right
D J D J turn to the left D J D J D J home D J D J home nicely done. So what we've been
describing so far is the together opposite hand path also known as air. We can also do D J
starting from a side beta here and we would be in a split opposite hand path which would look like
this. Let's do that together. Let's start in this side beta here thumbs in we could go either
direction but just to pick a direction I'm going to have my right hand come down and my left
hand come up D thumbs are still in J continuing that D J D J D J D J D J D J
would be equally valid to start from the other side so let's do it. Let's have the right hand
come up this time and the left hand come down ready D J D J D J D J we can also turn to either
side doing these split up variations just like with the toggle up variations. So let's start
on the right again thumbs in and this time we're going to actually start a little more
turned facing the right and the right is going to come down the left is going to come up
and then we turn our body towards the back and then following through with that motion the right
is going to come up the left is going to come down I'm going to have to twist all the way
around super twist following through with that the right comes up left comes down
and once again the right comes down left comes up we can follow that through all the way to
the other side. So now the right is going to come down in front the left is going to come
up in front D J and let's keep the direction going so now the right is going to come up
the left is going to come down as I twist my body to the left.
D and now I'm going to have to super twist go all the way over
for J and then follow through with that the right comes down left comes up
D follow through with that the right comes up left comes down
J we're almost home we just follow through one more
right comes up left comes down that was D and follow through once again
J and we're back where we started. Let's do that whole thing just two
times. Right down left up D right up left down
J right up left down D left up right down J following through turn to my
audience D now the right comes up left comes
down as I turn to the left J I follow through that the right
comes up left comes down as I turn to my left more D and I
follow through super duper twist all the way to the other side
j right comes down left comes up i follow through with that left comes down right comes up j
and two more steps d j one more time without so much talking one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
why are there twelve you might ask because there are four beats here there's four beats here and
there's four beats here and that adds up to twelve i could just as easily do dj starting
with thumbs out and if i did that the pinky end would stay into the center the entire time
dj dj and with turns dj dj dj dj dj dj dj